Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
March 7th, 2006 stay. What's going on?
How are you? How's your weekend?
Do you listen to the weekend?
I can't feel my face when I with you.
Boom.
Oh,
what are you doing man?
You're fucking some chicken blow. You
didn't do blow when you were with her now.
Now you're with her. Now
you're doing blow the boy.
I can't believe that shit came back.
You know, I thought coke was just done.
You know, after all the people did
what they did from my generation,
you would think that the next generations
would be like, you know what? Yeah,
I'm going to stay away from that shit.
Right.
It's not our works. One generation
does it. Like my generation,
we were like, wow man, let's
stay away from hey man,
like let's stay away from LSD and heroin.
Cause that's like a bad trip man.
And then we fucked with like coke and
crack crank, all of that Shit, right?
That ruined dollar about fucking lives.
And then the next generation was just
like, yeah, man, fuck all that stuff.
Let's fuck with crystal meth. Right?
So now this next way was like,
fuck crystal meth. You know, let's kick
it old school. Let's go back to the coke.
Right?
You have an entire generation of people
that not only can't feel it faces,
but I evidently they like it.
Oh God. What do you go from there?
Sorry, I'm trying to update my, uh,
my musical tastes.
I've decided that after fucking 40 years
of listening to the same fucking 10
bands, you know, not 40, like 30.
I mean, Jesus Christ, how many
fucking times can you listen to it?
I always like those. You have those
people are walking in the circle,
the circle in the jail
at midnight express.
Remember that when they were walking
counterclockwise and then the dude who's
going to escape and you had the drugs,
you know whose girlfriend put
it tidies up against the glass.
He started walking around the
other way. Remember that? Yeah.
That's what I'm doing right now. I'm
walking around the other way and every,
my generation is just going, what are
you listening to this shit for Sec.
I don't know how many times the Hay,
I haven't listened to
that for fucking 30 years.
Okay.
I gotta get,
I gotta pull my cell phone.
MMM.
No, I just, yeah, I would like to
listen to something new. So, uh,
the lovely Nia was watching the,
all the performances from
the grammys last night.
So I just started downloading
everything that I was seeing,
whether I liked it or not. I'm like, I'm
just gonna listen to this shit. You know?
It's kind of like when I try to put a new
hour of stand up together and I'm just
like, Eh, you know, if this
doesn't, this isn't a good idea,
but I'm gonna say it anyways cause I
can't say the other shit cause that's
coming out. So I just start
throwing shit against the wall.
So this morning I was listening to,
I listened to a little bit of the weekend,
Dude. Sounds just like Michael Jackson,
right? I think it does. And
uh, who else did I download?
That girl looks like [inaudible],
uh, MC search, right?
The fuck's her name.
I don't know if she was singing about a
relationship and she was over it and she
just looked like she had
this high top fade, you know,
but also knew what I like
to make a fucking rocket.
She looked really smart, you know, yet
like you wouldn't want to fuck with the,
I don't know. She kind of had it all
going on. It's like, is this a nerd?
Is this a bully?
Is this a wrapper or is she a witch?
But the band is fucking great.
And so she, I don't, you know,
after all of that shit,
I'm probably not going to say who the
fuck it is even if I figure it out.
Cause I don't want to shit
on people like that. Um,
anyways, he had a killer SG though.
The fucking three pickups, you know,
that's surfing green. They went
out, they crushed it. Right.
I actually saw what's his face?
They're the fucking,
the dude who's getting
the worst tattoos ever.
He's got the Lamborghini and fucking,
uh,
didn't like l and l Keyshawn Johnson
chased him up his front door.
The fuck is his name, Justin Bieber. I
actually watched that. That guy can sing.
He's fucking talented. I just don't,
you should just, just do that.
Just do that.
Stop filming yourself playing
basketball and whatever else is doing.
Mean mugging you.
Fucking Gopro.
Just sing your song and fucking go home.
Why wouldn't you do that?
It's actually a talented kid.
Although I didn't like when he threw
the acoustic guitar down in the end,
you know, what are you fucking
Pete Townsend? You're not okay.
You got the inner ear fucking monitor.
So you protecting your hearing. Okay.
You're not, you know, uh,
nobody's blowing up a drum set and part
of the fucking drum set goes right into
your fucking ear. Okay? Nobody's getting
crushed at your fucking concerts.
They've worked all of that
out. You know? Sorry. See,
and then I go right back to
the grumpy old man. I'm just,
I'm trying to give the kid a copies.
Fucking really talented.
He can actually really
sick. Um, so anyways,
and then I was listening the other
dude, what the fuck's his name? Uh, I,
for the life of me,
I don't understand why I can't just
download shit and then just find it.
And every fucking time it goes back
to the album thing. I, I could,
when they just list the songs,
I don't need to see the
picture of the album.
Every time this happens, I forget how to
do it. Oh, okay. Artists' songs. They are,
we go, um, oh. And speaking of which on,
um, everybody was, uh,
sending a bunch of each week when I do
the Thursday, uh, Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday
morning podcast. You know,
when we go into the greatest
hits of the Monday morning,
podcast is always a little musical
interlude. I do not pick that music.
That's Andrew Feminists.
And then he posts on the Twitter
site what the name of the music is.
So last week it was snarky puppy.
Okay.
That's who the fuck it was the posted
every week. Just fucking look it up.
All right. At the Mlm podcast
or some shit. I forget what the,
I don't know what the Twitter account is.
What am I going to fall on myself?
Um, anyways, plowing ahead.
So Friday night, oh, freckles.
I took a night off from
stand up. All right. Friday,
that's a big night to take a night off.
That's like not showing up thanksgiving,
you know, if you'd like to eat, you know.
So I went down to the Wiltern theater
and a with Andrew and I saw mute math and
they will fucking, unbelievable
cannot. I tweeted, I couldn't,
I cannot overstate how great
a fucking show that was.
And I wish I remember the name of the
opening band too. They were all so great,
but we're just killed me was,
I had never been to a show like that,
like whatever that style of music is,
I don't even know what
the style of music is,
but I'm just going from,
you know,
the Shit I've been listening
to for 30 years straight.
All right.
Wow.
Can Bajas Bhavin in cars.
Right.
I listened to say I listened to this same
90 songs for 30 fucking years in a row.
MMM. Never wanted to be that guy. So
just go into those, seeing those bands,
just how they use guitar,
where it's more used full,
like mood where,
but when I was growing up,
like the guitar was like the Dick
that got thrown on the table, right.
Just slaps you right in the face with it.
There was always the lead singer,
and then you had the guitar,
God,
and then the fucking dude playing rhythm
guitar who was not appreciated until at
least 25 years into that band's career.
You know,
like Malcolm young really
didn't get his props until,
until like the mid nineties I feel
Brad Whitford, same fucking thing.
You know, Ronnie Wood, all of these
guys just playing rhythm guitar,
holding the whole fucking thing together.
Right?
And they don't get shit for
the longest fucking time. Um,
Jesus Christ, Butte, math live man,
they're fucking unreal. So by the way,
they're playing Portland,
Oregon tonight. That's Monday,
depending on when you listen to
this Tuesday, they're in Seattle,
then they're off for a week, and then they
start back up again in Richmond. If a,
you get a chance to see them.
Um,
you will not be disappointed and
if you're an old fuck like me,
they were a great band to go see to
try to bring you into the modern era.
You know, if you're
listening to this, come on.
You can't tell me somebody is
a little bit younger than me.
You haven't been listening to that
fucking Pearl Jam record 10. You know,
whether all giving each other the
high five, the big Bro Picture.
We're all in this together.
All right.
Um, if you can't tell me that
you haven't been listened to it,
how many times are you going
to Dreher about her age?
Yay.
Oh,
fucking 25 years later.
I'm not saying don't have a
listen to it again, right? Look,
you can do whatever the fuck you want,
but I never wanted to be that guy
going [inaudible] it's him. You check.
Right then going into my house.
Babba dup, bup, bup, bup.
Betty [inaudible] bull ride going in
there and doing the fucking jitter bug.
That makes said that Jeff Beck is playing
the Hollywood bowl and I have to see
that guy.
He's like 70.
He's buddy guy is opening up and there's
no fucking way I'm going to miss that.
Um, you know, guys, one of
the greatest, he is the guy,
you know, I think from that whole
fucking error other than Jimi Hendrix,
I thought,
yeah,
I think you've got to give it to
Jeff back right now out of my mind.
I'm sure there's some black guy out
there that I'm forgetting. You know,
who got stolen from budgets as far as
white dudes who listened to black dudes
and then reshaped it. Right. I think
you've got to give it to that guy.
No. Well, you know, it's just my opinion.
You don't got to get fucking upset by it.
So anyways, what I'm obsessed with right
now as far as like the drummer, Darren k,
the guy's fucking insane.
And it was funny cause um,
you know,
Andrew got to know those guys,
so I got to go backstage and meet
him briefly. And uh, you know,
after the show they were going, hey, did
you learn anything watching our drummer?
And I was just like,
no.
And I heard that Darren goes,
ahhh. Like, I didn't mean it.
I hope I didn't come off in an
insulting way. It's like, dude,
Ikea too fucking far beyond anything
that I'm doing watching him.
It was like watching like Keith,
it was like Keith Moon playing drum and
base and then they have this sick ass
fucking light show going on. And I was
just sitting there squinting watching,
just going like, wow, what is he doing?
I ain't no fucking clue.
Um,
I did take one video while that
while they were playing, cause I,
I th this coolest,
you know,
the iPhone is and how great
the video is and everything.
I just fucking hate like being,
it's something and then just
sitting there filming it,
like I'm working for CBS
nightly news or some shit.
It's like I want to stand here
and I want to take this in.
There's enough other concierge
like filming this shit.
I can watch this. It'll be on the
internet forever. Right. So anyways,
there's this song clipping
that they play and
I had no idea what he was doing. And
Andrew's going to watch what he does here.
And then he literally has like two sticks
and a two drumsticks in his right hand
and he's playing,
this is going to be some drum geek shit.
So you might want to pass through this.
He's put bait as far as I can tell,
he's basically playing 68th
note, triplets, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. Two to two,
two to the three to four,
right. But he's only,
he's playing like he's doing
it with two sticks in one hand.
So the one on top sit in
the top of the high hat.
The one underneath is hitting the
bottom of the high end. So up top. What?
He's really just, he's playing like every
other note of the tripled. Like dot, dot,
dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
That uh, but he gets to, as
he's bringing that stick up,
the one underneath hits it. So that's
how he gets the full 16th note. Right?
Sorry. I know this is really nerdy
shit. And then with his left hand,
he's basically ghosting the offbeat and,
and then play in the backbeat on
two and four. And then dragon,
I believe on the final note of a,
the triplet into one.
That's what he's doing now.
I know. Let's drum nerd shit,
but I'll, I'll post the video.
It's fucking insane. Um, so of
course I went to the, you know,
went down to the studio the next
day and I tried to do it, you know,
for like 10 minutes, you know, a,
in whatever you learned something,
you know,
the first thing you do is you immediately
try to play it at the same tempo is
the drum God that you saw a play in it.
So it was really fucking frustrating.
I think I said, what the fuck, like
10 times. And then I just, you know,
just scroll through my Ipod,
iPad, whatever, my five
phone and I just, hey ma'am.
And just playing in the same shit of
him playing two for 30 fucking years.
I don't know what my deal is.
I can't get out of it.
Thank God I buy new clothes.
You know, if you should be like,
you should be forced to wear the clothes.
If you don't move ahead artistically,
your wardrobe shouldn't either. You
should be forced to fucking wear the same.
I should be wearing an acid wash jeans
with a fucking half shirt driving down
the street, my rusted out 83 Ford
Ranger. And they'd be like, listen,
if you're not going to progress with
the art of music, Yo, or whatever,
if you can watch the same
10 fucking films. Um, yeah,
I had no idea how far
behind I was. Um, so,
and I'm looking at mute math,
like they haven't been fucking
crushing it for 10 years.
I actually went on the Internet and
I looked them up and they liked,
did let them in 2005. There you go, Bill.
Wait to be on the cutting edge.
So whenever I feel like I
took a major step forward,
but I want to thank everyone
in the band for uh, you know,
letting us come back and say hello real
quick. Uh, Darrin, Paul, Roy and Todd,
you guys were fucking,
you crushed it.
And thank you to Andrew for
taking me down there and, uh,
pointing out what the fuck was
going on so I could, you know,
so the old man could
figure it out. But, uh,
I will definitely see those whenever I'm
in a city that they're in and I'm able
to do what it was that good of
a fucking show. And like I said,
they're in Portland then Seattle,
and they got a week off than
they were now Richmond. So, uh,
definitely check it out.
Anyways, plowing ahead here.
Um, so that was my Friday.
All right. So as a comedian,
there's no way you take a Friday,
Saturday off unless the UFC has a
fucking paper view and it's caught on.
And a Holly Holm at fighting, right.
So I'm like, all right, I got to watch.
I thought they were both title fights.
I didn't realize that Connor's
fight was not a title fight.
I think most people didn't realize that
most people like me got drawn into a
sport when there's someone like his,
you know, I go in and out of the UFC,
you know, like most shit.
I go in and out of cooking,
I go in and out of being a good comedian.
I've just, I'm in an APP, right?
I'm a fucking gem. And I, I'm into it.
I'm into it. Go Fuck Yourself. Hey,
remember that shit? And then I come
back. Right. Except with my music,
I just held onto it for just the
little, the little teeth, you know,
you can't always get what you well,
um,
what am I talking about? Anyways?
So we have a bunch of people over,
right? We go out, I go to the grocery
store, I get a bunch of, I get some booze.
I get, yeah, get some Gaba. Woo.
I guess some fucking Aig by war.
I get some fucking cheese and
all of that shit. I, I go on,
I get a bunch of ice cream sandwiches
after everybody's all fucking salt it up
with the Doritos and we sit
down to watch the shit. And, um,
what a fucking paper view,
man.
Yeah.
You know, spoiler alert, you know, if
you haven't heard yet, I'm going to say,
who won? I mean, you should
take beat Holly Holm,
you know,
and Nate Diaz beat Conor McGregor.
It was fucking unreal. My, I'm in.
Anybody else hosts a UFC fight party.
How fucking satisfied
did you feel was unreal?
I had like 10 people screaming,
Oh my God. Over and over again.
Like twice in one night,
flipping the fuck out.
More screaming and yelling during that
pay per view that I've heard in any super
bowl. You know, I dunno. Superbowl
party that had been to in a while.
Um,
it was unbelievable.
But Jesus Christ once again,
why always hate when like when a comedian
is getting ready for a special or a
late night spot and they say that
they trade like a fighter at the,
it's so disrespectful to what the men
and women do who fight for a fucking
living. It is, it is the most bad ass.
I'm trying to think of like a more Badass
job than that, other than, you know,
you're one of the grunts
on the front line in a war,
then your fucking job is you just train
your trading to beat the fuck out of
somebody who's training to
beat the fuck out of you.
And you both are professionals.
You do it for a living.
A whole crowd of people shows up.
You've ever fight after school.
And like 10 people showed up was fucking
nerve wracking. Fight, fight, fight.
You guys walk into a
fucking arena shortlist,
just walking down there and they got
to stare down some fucking maniac.
I live in there, own the,
on the ground. Right?
And that just taken fucking elbows and
they had the presence of mind to look
over at the clock.
Like how much more of this shit I,
another minute 38 of forearms
to my fucking forehead.
I don't know how they take it. So, um,
okay.
Unbelievable fight. I didn't realize
that, uh, had gone up in two way classes.
Like I said, I'm a very like,
novice fan of this stuff. Um,
okay.
But Jesus Christ,
fucking Nate Diaz sitting there and his
whole face is all bloody. And he says,
you know, I got this, I've taken your
worst shot. She can't knock me out.
It's just scar tissue.
I've bled before.
Okay.
I, I dunno, I dunno how to fuck you
do that. He was bleeding so much.
It looked like both of them were
bleeding to death because he,
once he got up against Mcgregor, whether
it was all over both of them, um,
I dunno,
I really don't have anything to say other
than I was blown away by both fucking
fights and um,
okay.
You know, it was hard as it is to
what I was was to watch Conor lose.
Cause I mean the guy's
a fucking superstar.
I'm talking shit and then backing it up.
Um,
okay.
It was still, you know, watching Nate
do his choking and fucking I was,
I was fucking unreal.
I don't know.
I don't know enough about the sport
to talk about it intelligently,
but I will say this,
I hate when someone like Connor
loses and then everybody, yeah,
you fucking pussy sale that
shit on the Internet. You know,
go on Twitter and start trashing the guy.
You know,
I want to talk to people right now.
If you're one of those people that do to,
how do you,
how do you like,
how do you do something like that and
like look yourself in the mirror when you
go to brush your teeth at night,
you know no one,
you haven't had a fight
since like the seventh grade.
You know the fuck is wrong with you.
If you all talked all the fucking shit.
That's what it made it
great sell in the fight.
I Dunno.
How great was that fucking lies
you just knocked out. Caught him.
I would choke dot Conor McGregor. How
does it feel? He grabs the mic goes,
I'm not surprised motherfuckers,
Chris,
I don't know about you guys,
but it's one of the fucking coolest things
I've ever seen. The fucking choke out.
Somebody as good as,
but Gregor that stand up all fucking
bloody and just walk around. Flex it.
Not even wiping the blood off, not
concerned about how fucked up your faces.
You don't give a fuck, right? Whatever.
Jesus Christ. The second, I got a little
scratch, I would have just, Oh my God,
am I?
MMM, that was great to see me.
She, uh, Misha went to, but I, I,
I as, as a fellow fair skinned person,
I felt bad for Holly Holm, you know,
just a second. We start
getting beat on just the, the,
our face just gets so fucking red and
then our yellow eyebrows stand out.
I just thought there was a lot
of mean Shit said about her. Uh,
when it came to that, I just come
really related to it. By the way.
What the fuck happened in Nate's,
the side of his face and his neck.
Okay.
Those scratches.
How did that happen?
Like somebody took like a
fucking, okay, you've got 10.
We took a knife down the side
of his face and his neck.
He's just sitting there
pawn at it. I, that's,
I've gotten scratched like that
every time somebody like exhale,
just the wind of that made me
go into the fetal position. Um,
but anyways, you know, as great
as that UFC pay per view was,
it's what just makes me so fucking
sad about what has happened to boxing.
If they could somehow,
if all the pieces,
shit promoters in boxing could just unify
and become one piece of shit promoter,
you know,
promotional entity like the UFC is right.
Cause you know, you know, you know, have
to deal, I don't know if you, if you're,
if you're, if you're in any
level of show business, you know,
the promoters of fucking over the ax,
you know, they are in an, in, in UFC,
it's the fighters, you know, I know on
some, I don't know anything about it,
but I don't want someone it,
they are getting fucked and because
they're a complete monopoly,
I'm sure they're fucking with their money.
I'm sure there's a pressure to make
people fight and that type of shit,
which is why they try to break
up monopolies. Having said that,
it's fucking great for the fence because
can the fact that the fighters have no
other options, it's just
the best fight the best. Um,
okay.
And like last night, like I haven't
had that kind of excitement,
like watching like a boxing pay per view,
like consistently the way the UFC is
consistently exciting like that since I
would say the middleweight division.
Um,
okay.
In the early eighties when you
had Roberto Duran, Tommy Hearns,
Marvelous Marvin Hagler and sugar
ray Leonard all fighting each other,
they all fought each other. They fought
each other numerous fucking times.
It was incredible.
Um,
I guess when Mike Tyson came along,
but that was just more the spectacle
of how quick was he going to just knock
these people out.
Um,
I dunno.
Just seeing a pay per view like that
and then seeing that it took fucking 10
years for the Mayweather Pacquiao fight
and then one of them shows up and he's
fucking hurt.
It doesn't say anything.
He doesn't say anything and you still
out 60 bucks is just fucking brutal.
So anyways,
um,
hats off to that fucking paper view.
Jesus Christ actually watched
some Mcgregor fight again.
MMM.
Unfucking believable.
I was just looking at the blood.
I'm going,
he's just going to keep fucking punching
him right in that I just keep punching
them right in that fucking,
I like,
who did that to that guy
with the fucking yellow hair.
Bleached hair was at fucking,
what the fuck was his name? GSP. I
can't even know their fucking names.
He just kept punching the dude in
the eye over and over and over.
And then it was always, I thought that
that's what my Greg was going to do.
Just keep punching native
and that fucking, I,
I just don't know how you doing? How's
fuck you sit there with him? I'm done.
Fucking done. You scratch
me. I am done. Keep fighting.
All right. I just keep saying
the same thing over again.
I was blown away by it and a respect to
everybody who fought there. Um, anyways,
uh, you know, it's weird to is
McGregor is still the champion.
Okay.
I didn't know that. I thought
it, I thought, I just assumed
to feel lost. That's it,
right? You're not a champ
anymore. We don't have the
belt. You're always a champ.
Right. I don't want to get out of this.
I don't know anything about the sport.
All right, let me, uh, let me get to the
advertising that, that always saves me.
Where the fuck is it?
Yeah.
Oh, for God sakes. There it is. There.
Oh, here we go. About about Bobby Ids. Me,
Andy's drying up.
You fucking Twat Badu to do Mondays
beyond A's is dry. Don't say that.
It's not okay. Um, Mondays,
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours
a day in your hand away.
Okay.
But instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes, you wash your
underwear is probably boring.
[inaudible] is here to change
that. They're going to give
you exciting underwear.
Introducing male panties.
Um,
please include the following.
It's pronounced modal.
No,
I don't know how many times they have to
miss this before I get some decent copy.
All right. It's all written in
lowercase m o h Dash D. A. L.
It doesn't tell me which
one does to fucking stress.
Okay.
It's either modal.
Or Madonna
model.
I was like,
no accent is that good.
Every pair of meundies is made from
sustainable sourced modal Madell a fabric
that's twice as soft as cotton.
Yeah.
Nothing can describe the fit
and feel of me undies. Oh,
when they get up against your balls,
a smile just comes across your
face like the Grinch on Christmas.
But once you try them on,
you're going to understand while they're
called why they are called the world's
most comfortable underwear.
Who calls him that? Why me?
UNDIES does.
Then I called the world.
They're called by you. You came up with
that and the fucking advertising, right?
I say when Michael Jackson just
called himself the King of Pop,
I'm the King of Pop. No,
are you twinkle toes?
What else are you you a little pot
and if you don't love your first
pair of me undies, they're free.
No questions asked me.
UNDIES has dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear. Whether
you can see them or not. Remember,
remember superman? Some, I think there
was a joke in there and I blew it.
A shipping is free and the U s and Canada
and you could save up to $8 a pair of
the me undies within me undies
subscription Pan, get plant,
get the subscription or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com
slash bar what do mean subscription?
What are you gonna have a new
pair of underwear every month?
It's like Columbia records and
tapes. Uh, that me, that's me.
undies.com/birth for 20% off your
first [inaudible] dot com slash bar Oh,
here we go.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody do you got a lot
of stubble on you face a UA.
Harry broad.
Do you want to shave you twat?
There is his birthday coming up
and you want to be all smooth.
We'll why don't you take out jog to can
have easy shave butter and put it on
your pussy is. Yeah,
you guys, I figured out,
I discovered the key to an amazing
shave. Evidently it's simple. That's the,
that's exactly what dollar
shave club.com does and why?
Evidently I'm a proud member
like millions of others.
They allege dollar shave club.com delivers
amazing razors right to my door for a
third of the price of what the greedy
razor corporations charge and they make
you go to the store,
Huh?
Those blue blooded cuts both my wallet
and face. Finally get some release.
Joining Dollar Shave club.com means you
can afford to shave with a fresh blade
anytime you want, which feels
fantastic. It's like new money, right?
You throw it in the fireplace
because you don't know any better.
And for the smoothest shave ever,
use your fresh dollar shave club
blade with their doctor. Cavities.
Easy shame.
It's not your average shave cream,
everybody.
This is high quality ingredients
that make your skin feel soft,
smooth and moisturized.
Your blade will just glide
gently across your skin.
If you want the most amazing shaves
possible, take it from me. Oh No,
take it from me. Take it from your
friends. You know, take a shit,
do whatever you want to do.
Use a fresh Dr Shade Dollar Shave Club
Blade with Dr cabbies. Easy shape butter.
Two reasons to join dollar
shave club.com/bird today.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar
high dollar shave club.com/burr.
And finally, lastly, I know
I got two more. All right,
so I'll take a break here.
Jesus Christ, we've got three more or
we got to get over the hump here, right?
MVMT watches movement watches
was started by Michael Victor.
Michael Tango. You know what that reminds
me? Is that that new Tina Fey movie,
whiskey, Tango Foxtrot. Is that,
is that not the worst advertise
movie you've ever fucking seen?
It just says whiskey, tango, Foxtrot. She
stayed in there, squinting into the sun,
holding a note pad and there's
something on fire behind her.
That's it. That's all I get. You know,
you can't hook her up with the little
fucking descriptive description.
I don't know. Maybe I'm old.
Maybe that, maybe that's,
that's the way the kids like it. They
don't want it. They don't want it.
What it says, it wasn't called
out as a slug line or some shit.
Okay.
I don't know.
Obviously it's right next to another
fucking billboard and there's like a,
like three Japanese looking dudes
holding shogun warriors swords.
And I know what that's about.
I know roughly where it takes place.
You can't just squinting into the sun
holding the notepad. You know, it's like,
is she an Arizona? Is there are
V on fire in the Grand Canyon?
Is she in Iraq?
I don't know.
Maybe that's what they're supposed to do.
Like I'm supposed to Pique my interest
and I'm supposed to go on the Internet.
But if you're someone like me who doesn't
know how to look up Shit, you know,
or starts to look something up and sees
a picture of something else and then
clicks on that and then two hours
later he goes, wait a minute,
wasn't I going to look something up? And
you can't fucking remember what it was.
I'm just saying, I think she's earned
a PR. I think she earned a, you know,
a little more respect than that.
Right.
Okay.
Dog. She hasn't made fucking
millions in box office.
Can you fucking help her out with
maybe half a sentence? Alright.
MVMT watches everybody movement watches
was started by two college dropouts with
the idea to make quality watches
that don't break the bank.
Starting at just 95 Joe Wallace,
there's and sold online.
They cut off all the
bullshit retail markup.
Supposedly movements sent some watches
over here. Question Mark. Yeah,
they did.
Okay.
Why don't I just get this generic copy,
Huh?
Am I going to go a little Kanye West
right now and have a fucking hissy fit?
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, what? Why can't, why
can't they fucking, you know,
supposedly moving. Why don't you
send some over here? Yeah, they did.
I already talked about it. Why would
you put that in the copy? You know,
I'm going to read it.
I'm like Ron Burgundy.
I'm Rundberg quality
materials and sleek designs.
The perfect everyday watch. It's easy
order online today for free shipping,
free returns and a 24 month
warranty. That's pretty good, Huh?
$95 a watch with a two year warranty.
Join the movement and say no to big brand
retail markups and say saying yes to
great style checkout. Mv amped to
delay means say no to big brand retail.
If you could afford a Rolex, you wouldn't
go fucking do it. Of course you would.
All right. Let's call a spade
a spade. Here, you want a
Rolex? You can't afford one,
but you don't want to have
some piece of shit. This, this,
this is where you're at in life for $95.
Fucking watch.
That's going to look like a $800
watch. Okay? We've all been there.
God dammit.
Go to MV empty fucking watches.com.
There's no fucking in there slash bar
and you get 15% off your entire purchase.
That's MVMT watches.com/burr.
All right. Jesus Christ.
Hey, you know what it did last
night? It rained here in California.
It never rains in California,
but both I don't. They
booed. Yeah, it pause man.
It Paul's sorry. Um, I was
sleeping upstairs last night.
Oh, fucking Joey Rose's
swung by the house. We had a
couple of cocktails, right?
And then he went home.
Ubered it like the hipster that he
is over two is hipster neighborhood.
You know,
there's fucking
his jags on or whatever the kids were
wearing nowadays. And uh, I don't know. I,
the only time I snort
is when I fucking booze.
So I wasn't going to do
that to the lovely Nia.
So I crashed upstairs and um,
it started thundering
and lightening at night.
And what's fucking hilarious about living
out here slash terrifying is it never
rains.
So when you hear thunder,
you automatically think it's a fucking
earthquake, but you bed isn't moving.
So you kind of like,
well, wait a minute, am I,
I've never heard an earthquake
that I couldn't feel.
And you've got to like do the math
when you're half asleep going like,
is that like an earthquake?
And you know,
in the valley and I can't fucking hear
it. I can hear it, but I can't feel it.
That that doesn't make any sense.
And then you find figure, oh my God,
that's thunder. Holy Shit. It's
fucking raining out. Right.
What does that in French, you split,
you'll player. I can't fucking remember.
I suck at that shit in edge.
It is snowing.
Um, anyway, so starts
fucking rating and uh,
it's tremendous. It's rained a bunch. It's
an El Nino year. Thank Christ. And, uh,
but what I was always in the depressing
thing in the back of my head is as green
and is lushes the hills.
Look right now. Um,
this is like basically the only rain
we're going to get for the next fucking
three years.
And I know every cunt out here has taken
long showers now going hey to folk and
droughts over, you know, I just hope, uh,
I dunno.
I hope it fucking rained.
Keeps raining as much as it possibly
fucking cans or we can't or there's a
massive God damn play gout here. One of
the other, something's got to give. Right.
That's depressing isn't all right,
let's get into um, oh no, wait,
I was gonna tell you another thing.
So yesterday I was just driving around,
hanging out with my wife and a,
they get a bunch of open houses out here,
so I can't fuck it. Let's go
look at some houses, you know,
get some ideas for our old ass kitchen.
See what a real kitchen looks like. Right.
And,
um,
I got to tell you haven't bought this
house and gone through all this shit that
I've gone through.
I look at houses entirely different.
I'm immediately looking at the windows.
Do they have the old ass original windows?
Um,
and I immediately want to go downstairs
if there's a crawl space, anything,
I want to go down there
and I'm smelling for water.
And you can't really do that a lot
out here because a, they don't,
it doesn't rain enough. But I immediately
look underneath the fucking house.
I look right up it's fucking
skirt. Like the home pervert. I am.
And I'm immediately looking
for, all right, let's see. What,
what does the electrical work look look
like? You know, is it galvanized pipe?
What kind of Shit Hole, you know,
looking at how stuff is put together.
Does this look like it had
a permit or not? And um,
you know,
all the sexy shit goes away.
Like we have a pool and I'm
just looking at it going like,
and it's okay and it looks like a piece
of shit to me that looks like you need
to Redo the whole floor
of that fucking thing.
And so you've got to dump out all the
fucking water and evidently you can't fill
your pool up with water anymore out here.
You have to fly the fucking water in.
So fuck that pool. I haven't got it in
the house yet. You know there's a classic,
they're saying it's a two car garage,
but it is if you dry,
if you drive to model t Fords,
but if you have any sort of modern car,
you're not going to be able to get
the all, you can get two in there,
but nobody can get out of the cars.
So I was just a negative
Nelly and actually realized
that my house isn't as bad
as I thought it was.
Now that I fucking dumped every
fucking dime that I have into it. Um,
not made me feel good. I was just
walking in the kitchen. I'm like,
there's no prep space here.
All this disco shit.
I don't see any place where I could
fucking slice an English muffin.
You know what? Fuck this
kitchen. Fuck the pool.
Fuck the kitchen and fuck this
galvanized pipe. Oh look at this. Oh Wow.
Rugs, rugs in every room. Yeah. Take
your shoes off. Why is that? Yeah,
cause the floors haven't been refinished
and fucking 80 years. Fuck these floors.
Let's go upstairs. Oh Great. I see
this used to be an addict. Oh yeah.
You call him that an office. Yeah. Yeah.
I like how you're showing
it during the winter time.
Cause I know what happens in
the summertime. It fucking
heats up up here. Right.
It could grow a fucking goddamn bullshit
Bushel of fucking marijuana up here if
he fucking three hours.
Fuck this office. Right.
You want to sign up on
our mailing list now?
I don't because you're selling
piece of shit houses. And then that,
that said I walked and I was done.
And of course I upset my wife
cause all I did was just, sorry,
I actually only just shut off
the fucking recorder. I actually,
I upset my wife because, you know,
she's like, I like, you know,
I thought we could just have fun.
I don't understand why you have to go
in the house and be rude to the real
estate people say I don't
like those people. You know,
cause they don't encourage you
to sell your house, you know,
air quote for a fucking profit.
So then you can buy back into the same
market and then everything you just made
on your house,
you've got to buy it.
You got to spend again just
to get the same fucking house.
I actually said that to the guy. I think
that's, that's made my wife met and I go,
yeah, the only people making money
out of here are you in the banks.
And the guy's like, whoa. Well that's
not necessarily true. Yeah. Do the math.
Tell me how that works.
Can we get you to the mailing list?
Um, all right, let's let
some fucking questions here.
Questions here for the Goddamn Week.
Casco,
Casco say mall something, right? What is,
what does,
I don't fucking know.
Guess could tell.
I'm just never going to get it.
You know what? I don't, I just,
there's no reason for me to speak it.
All right, let's, let's plow ahead here.
All right. Um, the March 3rd podcast,
fucking brilliant podcast yesterday,
March, March 3rd, 2016. Thank you.
One of the very best,
and I've heard hundreds of your podcast.
Nobody drowns in their own vomit
anymore. Great Brain, dude.
Thank you Greg and hamburger. Let me
know if you're coming over here. Well,
that's not a fucking question.
Yeah,
it's just a con. Yeah. We don't compliment
this questions. That's it. Well,
thank you. I'm going to be doing Germany
hopefully towards the end of the year.
I'm definitely getting over
there. All right. Um, okay.
Guy who invented the invented email
died.
He said Uncle Freddy died.
Uncle Freddy. Hey Bill,
I'm sending you an email about the
guy who invented email dying today.
This is my way of honoring what he did.
I imagine he'll get very little
press because Nancy just say,
no.
Reagan died this weekend too.
Here's an article from an here's an
excerpt from an article, uh, about him.
Internet Hall of Famer raid.
Tom Wilson has died.
Tom Olson was the man who basically
invented email as we know it today,
including making the choice to use
the at sign in an email address.
He was 74 years old. Tomlinson,
I think I said his name wrong,
the first time.
Tomlinson invented email assistant
where a user on one network could send a
message to someone on the another network
in 1971 oh they left some of it out of
there. Thomason invented
a network. I mean,
I'm going to read it the way I see
it. Tomlinson or Tom Wilson, however,
I feel like reading
Tomlinson invented email,
a system where it user on one network
could send a message to someone on another
network while the government,
advertisers and hackers could all
read your private information.
This was invented in 1971 had Tomlinson
had any idea what people were going to
do with his invention.
What do you have made it?
What do you have invented it and the
answer is of course he would of how else
was he going to get some pussy?
All right. This was his slug like,
Hey, can you meet my fucking
friend Tomlinson over here?
I don't want to beat him that
he invented email. Oh my God.
Hey you
can I touch your peepee?
Um,
that's actually really interesting.
There's Internet Hall of famers.
Now I have to look that up.
Who's in the Internet Hall of fame?
Jesus Christ. I want to see images too.
I want to see what the fuck these
people look like. Internet Hall of fame.
Here we go. Come on, man.
You Internet Hall of fame homepage.
Holy Shit.
2014 hall of fame inductees. I didn't
know this. This is fucking awesome.
Internet Hall of fame.
Paul vixy internet piracy will
let me see the list. Inductees.
All right, here we go. Here's
a list. Here's a list of who.
Who is it? All right.
Here's some of the pioneers,
so look at these fucking
eggheads. Jesus Christ. Wow.
Wow.
Oh my God.
If I could do a fucking
screenshot of this, I got to
put the link up here. My God.
What is it about being
super smart and just,
I guess everybody gets one gift. I'll
tell these people. This is a rough one.
You know there's a lot of fucking lonely
prom nights on this page. All right,
Douglas Engelbart and he's as good
looking as that fucking name. Oh,
he looks like a sweet old man.
Let's see what this
guy doggy Jesus Christ,
he's got the old man face in 1963 Dr.
Angle bars founded the augmentation
research center lab at SRS.
Yeah.
So how do you tell a woman that that's
your dream and she's not going to glaze
over. Try doing that while that. Fuck it.
I can't feel my face when I'm with you.
I said I want to start the
augmentation research center lab.
Where are you going?
Um,
where he pioneered a system for augmenting
human intellect in which workers
sitting at display workstations could
collaborate on solutions to humanity's
problems through a vast
online information space.
Okay.
Did, did it matter that no
one ever fucking uses it?
Look at this guy. He fucking
the, see this is what all these,
these guys are off and
all these men and women,
their heart's in the right fucking place.
And then these fucking lunatics in these
corporations see sociopath's get their
fucking manicured fingers on these things.
All right, Susan Astrada you could tell
she was a looker back in the day. Got It.
Been all these guys fucking
jerked off to her, Huh?
When she came around the
fucking augmentation lab,
Susan area. Um, this
is probably why she's,
this is probably the woman,
why they're there. She was,
this woman here was probably the
inspiration for the fucking, uh,
virtual reality sex suit that
they're trying to work on.
A strata founded c e r f Surf Net,
one of the original regional IP networks
in 1988 surf net serves the academic
and commercial communities in California.
I still don't even know what
it is as an executive director,
she took the initial national science
foundation funding two point $8 million
and grew the network from 25
sites to hundreds of sites.
I don't know what it does.
Okay.
All right. Let's, let's
look at this. Look,
Dennis Jennings Sky looks like a fucking
NFL ref from 1958 as the first program
director for networking at the
u s National Science Foundation.
Dr. Jennings was responsible for the
design and the development of NSF net
program.
Yeah.
No way he did that. I have no idea what
in these fucking people did. Come on, man.
It's trying to find somebody. Looks for,
okay, this guy's not a bad looking guy.
Oh yes he is. He is. And
he's got a full head of hair,
but you can just see he's a spazz.
You know,
he's one of those guys seemed sorta cool
until he starts laughing. I like, yeah,
I'm all right.
Eric Beano Beano cocreated with fellow
Internet Hall of Famer Marc Andreessen,
the first version of the mosaic web
browser in 1993 I think I've kind of know
what that is. Alright. You know what?
And with that, and I'm fucking bored.
Just like the chicks walking away
from these people at the blah. Um,
yeah.
Internet Hall of Famer. Well, you know
what moment of silence for Ray Tomlinson.
Okay.
His heart was in the right place.
Who knew that pedophiles
would use his invention
to send pictures and shit. All right.
From Scotland, dear Billy, big dicks.
I've had been,
I've been working flat out and work back
in Scotland and now taking a three week
vacation in the u s I'm 27 years old
and have never been across the pond.
So this is a big deal for me.
Well, welcome a chance to see you
nutcases up close and personal.
I'm Planning Vegas,
Death Valley and Grand Canyon to see some
outdoor epicness then onto Chicago to
see the black hawks wiped the floor
with the flyers. Wow, man. That's,
that sounds like a great trip.
Then Paddy's Day. Oh boy. Um,
then New York City to
pop my weed. Sherry. Um,
to a first timer in the u s what
would be your top three things to do?
I would really appreciate
the advice. Alaska. Fuck
yourself. You're big Nancy boy.
Okay. The three things I would do. Well,
I mean you're kind of doing, you're
doing some amazing shit. Alright.
Defi if I was coming to America,
what would I do?
Okay,
dude, I live here. I don't know what
the fuck to do. That's like, you know,
you never know what the touristy
shit is to do when you're,
you're telling you to your own place.
You take it for granted.
Like when I lived in New York,
I never went to this.
I went to the Statue of Liberty once
I went, when my grandmother visited,
you know, I didn't do any of that shit.
I was just trying to get to work. Um,
all right. If I had to pick three
cities, I would do a shit. Only three.
Okay.
All right. You got to go to
New York. I would say Chicago,
but you get enough New York with Chicago.
I would see San Francisco and then
you'd have to do something down south.
Um, you know, just to get, I don't know,
you'd get both coasts and then you get
down south there and all of those are
their own fucking worlds.
What would I do? I don't know.
Going on a black hawks
game is fucking great. Um,
yeah,
dude. You know what? You stumped
me. I don't know what I would do.
I would go to New York like you're going
to do and I would fucking do as much
shit as I can. You can't miss
there. That was a nice vague answer.
Um,
the fuck would you do?
I don't know.
I live here.
I don't know what the fuck would I
do if I went to Scotland. Go ahead.
Gimme gimme your mushy p ideas.
I guess I would, I would go to,
I go to a rugby game. I think you know
something. If you're going somewhere,
you have way more ideas and
the person who's living there,
I can't believe I can't think of
anything to do. I, you know what?
I go to a fucking steak house.
You know what?
I would definitely indulge in the
fucking cuisine over here. There we go.
I'm getting my foot in here. All
right. You go into a hockey game.
I'd go to a sporting event or
any sort of fucking basketball,
anything you could see if he can go
see the fucking golden state warriors.
They one of the Becka regular
season records of all time.
If you can take in a fucking show,
go see mute mass for fuck sakes. Um,
I dunno what I would do, dude,
I'd go down south, right?
I go to a fucking gun range. Do
something like that. You want,
this is what you want to do.
You want to do some metropolitan shit,
you want to do some sports shit and
then you got to do some backward,
backward shit. That's
what I would do. You know,
go find somebody drinking some moonshine
out of a fucking jar, a mason jar,
and then,
you know,
have him fucking smoke a God damn pork
shoulder and go out and shoot his guns.
They go ride some four wheelers,
you know,
do something like that. I Dunno, you know,
a lot of people sleep on like Wyoming,
Montana, the Dakotas. Those
can all be fun to go see.
And I can send you guys live in
that little ass country, you know,
I dunno dude.
I'd ran a fucking classic American car
and we now went from fucking New York to
Chicago. I would drive that and
I wouldn't take the highways.
I try to find some old route and I'd stop
off the greasy spoons. Sammy, you go.
There we go. Jesus. I, there's a
couple of ideas. I'm sorry dude.
I really fucked you over on that.
Went butter.
I don't know.
That's like when somebody,
you remember back in the day when
you actually shopped, you know,
you bought CD's and stuff.
I used to have all these CD's I'd want
to buy and then when I would walk into
virgin, I can never remember what
the fuck I wanted. I'm sorry man.
I really dropped the ball on that one.
All right. To a first timer in the EU.
That's not it. Uh, podcast got me
in trouble with fiance's family.
Uh, hey there. Billary Berm Clinton. Um,
I fucked up man. And she can
probably guess from the subject line.
Okay.
Cue The old Jj.
Um,
as a little background, I'm getting
married next month to my fiance,
who is wonderful love
of my life and all that.
We were visiting her family last
night and playing board games,
which we often do. Oh, Jesus. Oh,
what happened? Were you drinking?
Did you get competitive? Huh?
Gee accuse her mom of cheating.
Uh, he goes, I'll spare you the details,
but we were playing a card game
with a bunch of characters.
Everyone gets the same people,
but when you use them is
really the key to the game.
There was a particularly powerful card I
had held onto until the very last stage
of the game.
The character's name was granny water.
MMM.
Pronounce Gary Water.
I gave you the pronunciation and accent
so you wouldn't fuck it up. Well,
it is spelled w a t a granny.
Why?
It's the last round of the
game and everyone's going
around revealing their card.
I was last and my plan
had worked perfectly.
As I went to reveal it,
my inner bill bird took over and I really
got excited. I flipped it over. Oh,
you did it? He goes, oh
no. Oh No. He goes, I said,
it's granny.
Yeah,
Dude. You drop the F bomb. Oh my God,
I wish I had podcast tee
shirts. I'd send one to you. No,
you did. He goes, silence followed
as it echoed through the house.
My fiance's family were stunned.
They're not super uptight people,
but people just don't just don't throw
fucks around during a board game.
You know, from there it only got worse.
My fiance is listened to your podcast,
so she knows I was imitating you.
She tried to stammer out an explanation
or no, she had to explain a way,
your behavior.
Ah Dude.
He goes, but it didn't really do anything.
I also tried to apologize sheepishly.
Then on top of that,
that move gave me enough points,
win the game over everyone.
So I had to awkwardly mark my score,
which made me the winner.
Wow,
dude.
Oh,
when you're getting married next month,
so the fucking taste of this is still
going to be in their mouth. He goes,
we left almost immediately after and of
course I got yelled at all the way home.
I knew I deserved it,
so I didn't even put up much of a fight.
That's your first good move in
this story. Oh Wow. He goes,
my question is do I try and go out of
my way to remedy this situation or do I
just hope everyone forgets
about it and moves on?
We're getting married in six weeks,
so it's not like I can avoid
them for very long, um,
perse because I fucking
crush the impression too.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Sorry for the Hillary Clinton referencing
the opener. I think she's a cunt to, uh,
I don't think she's a contract.
Just don't think she's an honest person.
And I don't think just because of
the fact that we've never had a woman
president that that's reason enough to
elect someone is dishonest and as phony
as her. Um, anyways, though,
you know what, I would,
I would actually, uh, without your wife.
I would just drive over there and
just say, listen, I got to apologize.
I listened to this podcast.
I'm a big fan of the guy. Um,
I was making a joke and in the moment
I didn't realize that you guys didn't
listen to the podcast if you want
and just kept queue up a clip. Well,
you have it, which might be
a bad thing to do, but like,
just have me like saying something else,
doctor cabbies,
easy shave butter. But then you might
be fuck, cause I don't say fuck.
MMM.
Just say, just tell him you're
really embarrassed or whatever.
I think if you went over there
by yourself, I think, uh,
especially her dad,
cause I think that's the big one there.
I think there's, there's something
extra when it's, you know,
it's always extra, you know, when,
when you're getting married like a,
okay.
You know, if you're a guy, you know the,
the dad's going to be looking at you
twice as hard and the mom, she'll be like,
oh, he's no, it's relax. You know? And
then the other way around is if, you know,
they have a son and he
brings it a woman around,
like the mother's going to be fucking
looking at her to see if she's a fucking,
you know, an evil little whore. You know,
the dad's going to be looking at you like,
cause this guy going to be overbearing
and slap my fucking daughter. Right.
Or whatever. You know what I mean? See a
piece of shit. Right. Um, oh my God, dude.
Wow. You said it's granny. Fuck.
Oh God, dude, if you film that, oh my God.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. Dude, I got to
give it. I got it. My tip of
the cap for you there, man,
for doing that.
Holy Shit.
I'm getting uncomfortable just thinking
about that. Well, can I, I'll apologize.
Can I apologize to your fiance
for being a bad fucking a bad,
um, influence. Hey, you know what? Play
this to a play this tea a year, a year.
Future inlaws dear future in
laws. Hello. I'm bill burr.
I'm the one who says granny.
I say this type of stuff. I've been
the bad influence. Don't be mad at him.
I'm sure he's a wonderful human being.
I'm sorry. Messed up. He messed up.
You're a little kid game there. Um, yeah,
he's going to make a great son in law.
You know why? Cause he uses Dr cabbies.
Easy. Shame. Don't play that to them.
That's not going to get you into anything
that's going to say he listens to
morons. He must be a moron. Are they
going to have half a moron kid? All right.
Not eating birthday cake.
Huge fan of the podcast is a 27 year
old who works in a stereotypical white
collar suburban office.
I thoroughly enjoy,
listen to you by your biweekly
rants at my desk. Wonderful man. Uh,
speaking of which,
I work in the corporate offices of a
sales and distribution company that has
about 50 employees,
but only about 15 people work
in my specific office location,
which means that about once every
motherfucking month we gather in the big
conference room and do the cliche
awkward office Happy Birthday Song.
Oh No. With candles and cake
routine and all of that.
What I am by, no me. Okay. Well
I am by no means a health nut.
I also try very hard to take care of
my body during the workday by eating
properly and drinking lots of water.
I've also gotten really into
bike racing over the past years,
which has taught me a lot about the
importance of nutrition, etc. Uh,
so the thought of eating a giant piece
of chocolate cake at two 30 in the
afternoon when my eyes are pre practically
bleeding from staring at a computer
screen all day,
we do nothing but make me
feel like absolute shit and
I really have no interest.
Very smart. Uh, this is why
for the past couple of years,
I politely turned down every piece of
birthday cake that has been offered to me
at these after mentioned ceremonies.
Unfortunately,
I am the only one at my coworkers,
most of whom are women who has
adopted this no cake philosophy.
So every single time I stick,
I stick out like a sore thumb after I
declined the piece that is passed to me,
at which point I have to deal with this
wave of passive aggression from these
ladies regarding my decision to
abstain from the sacred ritual.
I also share a birthday
with one of my coworkers.
So I am spared some of the awkwardness
that goes along with from fusing cake on
my own birthday, but still made
out to be some kind of monster.
Okay, Jesus going on and on here. Well,
I have no intention of succumbing to
the peer pressure brought forth by my
colleagues.
This might be the best written fucking
letter I've ever had on the podcast.
Is it possible that I'm being rude
by not sharing in the celebration?
What's more is that even if I found out
people did that I was being douchey by
not eating cake, I still wouldn't
give a shit what they think.
Does this make me a
sociopath? No, it doesn't.
It makes you somebody who knows what he
wants and everybody else's do you know,
you just, you just get, you know what you,
you need to just get a little space here.
A couple of little verbal,
you know,
you know the great ones create space
and all, you know, football, hockey,
basketball. You don't have to do that
baseball. But you know what I mean?
The great ones create space.
Okay?
So what you have to do is you have to
tap into your greatness and you have to
create space. Okay? And
just say, look, people,
it's not that I'm not happy
that it's your birthday.
I just don't want to become a lard
ass. I mean, I'm not being a dick here,
but you know a lot of you,
I'm not gonna say who over the years,
your slacks just keep getting bigger
because you keep eating all this fucking
cake.
All right?
You blowing out your bodies and I'm not
going to be a part of it and a part of
me dies every time I watch
you guys eat in this shit.
But if that's what you want to do,
by all means go ahead and do it.
But I'm not going to become a fucking
cow like most of you guys are.
You know what I mean? Half of you should
have bells around you fucking next.
Alright, there you go. You
just know, right? They'll
never ask you for cake again.
You probably want to get invited,
you know,
that's what fucking a, this was
Sydney Crosby would do. Right.
Okay.
Mario Lemieux the great ones
to create space. No, dude,
you're not a sociopath, right? You're
doing the right thing, you know,
I dunno. I Dunno why women like
sweet so much. You know, I actually,
I like sweets. I'm just
a big fruit basket. Um,
I actually like sweets,
but when I stay away from him for awhile,
if you really abstained from
fucking desserts and everything,
if you walk into a place that
has a bunch of crazy desserts,
it doesn't even look like,
like edible for human consumption.
You know what I mean? It looks, I
always said it looks like clown food.
You know what I mean?
Like a clown sneezed.
Especially if it's really like a lot of
like fruits and fucking whip cream and
all of that shit. Just like this. It looks
ridiculous. It's always crazy colors,
Greens and purples, right? You
don't want the right thing.
There's all I'm saying you're
doing the right thing, you know,
is in the bike race and
you're working out, you know,
this is the deal that you've
actually got a chance of bagging,
banging one of those fucking
cake eat and broads at in,
in your section because they,
they're going to see like a half of
them are probably just testing you.
The other half are fucking probably
codependent fucking cake eaters and they
feel guilty, you know, and they
know that after they eat that,
then that sugar is going to be in their
veins and then they're going to go back
to their desk and they're going to start
eating a handful of fucking cheddar
flavored goldfish to shoving them down.
You know?
I bet if you walked around your little
section and you have the cubicles and you
looked at their keyboards,
I bet keyboards or greasy a bit.
There's crumbs in them. I don't
know. You know what? I think you,
I think you have to go to work
there when you think about that.
That's what I got out of that
fucking letter. All right.
Here's your podcast for this week.
I want to thank everybody for listening.
Did I read all the Ai to do all
the fucking advertising? God Damn.
Bill said they're running your
fucking mouth. What do I got next?
I'll trunk club everybody.
Trunk Club. All right.
Don't waste a second of the new year
in a crowded mall with trunk club.
You can make 2016 your
most stylish here yet,
and he never have to go
to the god Damn Mall.
You don't have to do any work yourself.
Someone else is gonna do it for you.
You know, it's like you're rich and
you have your own fucking stylist.
It's going to be a game changer.
You get a fresh start,
you start the year off on the
right foot and the right pants,
the right jacket or the right panty
loans and a mental right moment though is
blog, uh, over the right shirt.
Shimmies a trunk club is here to handle
your wardrobe so you can focus on what
matters, what matters, how going
out there and getting it up.
Slice of fucking pie,
please include all the following points.
Trunk Club takes the hassle man out of
shopping by finding the best clothes for
your style.
You're going to look like a million
bucks@trunkclub.com slash [inaudible] all
you do is actual answer some
simple questions about your
style, your preferences,
size, and you're assigned and
expert stylist. All right?
Then you styles goes down.
Just picks from the best premium band.
They sent a trunk of that Shit over here.
You keep what you like and send back
what you don't and the prepaid trunk,
they take out all the fucking middleman
from all the bullshit and a yeah,
and for some reason the crop he keeps
going on and on. You get what goes on.
All right. Where do
you go? Take advantage.
He'd go to trunk club.com/burr trunk
club.com/bar hey trunk club.com/burr oh by
the way, it's a brand new year. A trunk
club. We'll send you stuff for free,
right? Shipping's free
both ways. Go there,
get some clothes, Cynthia
House. You like it, keep it get,
don't send it back in the fucking trunk.
Can't make it any easier than that.
All right,
stamps.com do you like going to the
post office while half fun Fucko cause
everybody else is doing stamps.com
trips to the post office that never
convenient.
So why not get postage right from your
desk with stamps.com stamps.com even
gives you special postage discounts.
You can get at the post and
you liked that one knee.
Yeah. Uh, including. Okay.
Use using your own computer and printer.
You can buy and print official US
postage for any letter or package.
Then just hand it to your mailman,
your mailman or your mail lady
or drop it in the mailbox.
It said easy.
No wonder over 500,000 small businesses
are already using stamps.com.
I use stamps.com whenever I whore
myself out, sending out my posters.
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you right now you can sign up for
stamps.com and use my last name Barbie.
You are our for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer
that includes postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait, get a don't wait. Get
started with stamps.com today.
Don't go to just go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top,
the whole page and type in bur
bur that stamps.com enter burden.
Hey,
there's this guy at work,
work, work, work, work, work.
Oh, you know what, I'm trying
to listen to modern music.
That one I can't listen to.
She sounds like she got roofie lag.
Lag Man. Grab bag. How
about uh, uh, uh, uh, um,
okay.
And she's one of those people,
you have to watch her doing the song
cause she's so beautiful. You like,
all right, I can deal with this,
but I want, it's just their voice.
Like he'd break up with her over
the phone. What? Rianna yeah,
she called me up and be like,
yeah, we have to break up, up, up,
blah blah. Sorry. Okay. All right.
Shut up. Don't judge me. I'm an hour
in. I'm out of jokes. That's why.
So this guy works at this
fucking office and uh,
he's got into cycling and working out
in nutrition and that type of thing.
So there's like 15 people in his
little area of the office. So he goes,
that means about at least once a month,
he has to go down to the fucking cafeteria
and sing happy birthday to somebody
and then they're passing
around birthday cake.
So he always says he doesn't want the
birthday cake. And then they're like,
uh oh you would for a girl you can kick,
you gotta eat it too or will feel guilty.
And he's like,
am I some sociopath that
I don't give a shit?
Should I stick to my guns
or should I just have cake?
Oh stick.
You got to stick to your guns and you
should tell people that you're on a diet.
Cause people are like, oh
that's great. Yeah. You know,
cause I had been really trying to lose
weight too. I mean obviously not today.
And you know,
say that as they're about
ready to eat a piece of cake.
What do you mean you can't go into a crack
house and tell everybody that you got
sober and the crack heads are
going to be like, oh that's great.
Hey, well I mean you can
still, you're right. But you
can still say no. None for me.
I'm,
I'm trying to watch my weight.
That's when they come back now just
to have one piece. Then you go, hey,
fatty. Yeah. Said no it does.
I know I'm really can't.
I've been doing really well this
last month and I'm really, you know,
I really feel good and I'm just, you
know, just no fucking peer pressure.
Office offices are the worst for that
type of shit. When I worked in the office,
yeah, it was always someone's
birthday. Someone's always like,
I made brownies over the weekend and I
just like can't have them in my house
anymore. You guys ate them and it's, it's,
it's hard because everyone's just eating.
You're sitting in a fucking cubicle
all day. You're bored is shit.
It's probably the vending machine.
Nice.
Your question,
is it true that that bid bitches be
eaten when they're at the office?
Why? Why, why all
bitches be eating the male and the female
bitches all be eating white, white,
white bitches be, why bitches
be he and I don't know. Bb
Office environments are so hard to
be on a diet with cause it's, yeah,
it's like food constantly because it's
so fucking boring to sit there all day.
You just eat, eat, eat, eat.
So no say no to the cake.
All right, one last quick one. All right.
Cause I got into speaking of that, this,
this fatty kicks me to take her ass
to the gym. So it looked good to me.
Thank you.
But it starting today,
since I'm going to my
reunion and starting today,
why can't you get in shape
for me? Um, I mean I'm,
yeah,
why are you first of all,
don't try to hijack my health goals.
It's not about you.
Okay. It's about me. I do a head spin in
there for a second. All right. Kelly did.
How do I help this guy helped this guy.
All right,
so we sort of backtracking
here on the podcast. All right,
I'm just going to paraphrase this.
Ah, the podcast got me in trouble.
This dude's getting married in six weeks.
He's over his don't read it.
Just listen to me. I know. I
heard you talking about it. Oh,
did he say really loudly heat. So
they're playing a card game. Yeah,
he has the co the Trump card. That's gonna
fucking beat everybody. Right. And um,
the name of it is his
granny water w a d eight.
So when he plays it epes the Alaska,
he slammed it down and nobody
listens to the police. Parents,
his future in laws do not
listen to the podcast.
And he just slammed it down and he goes,
I gotta I gotta read it.
He goes,
it's granny.
Yeah.
And it was just silence followed
as it echoed through the house.
My fiance and family were stunned.
This not super uptight people,
but people just don't throw fucks around
during a board game, you know? Yeah.
It only got worse is his fiance to Oh,
he listens to the podcast and it just,
yeah. And she yelled at him the hallway,
see what you're doing to people, getting
them in trouble with her future in laws.
I think you owe that young man an apology.
I did apologize and I apologize.
I made them a little fucking audio thing
that he can play. The two is, uh, in loss.
Oh, is it filled with you saying fuck
over and over again? Why? I had the,
I don't know if that was going to help,
but I had to do it in a way
that they like, you know,
saw what a bad influence on.
Oh, it's just a silly awkward moment.
It's fine. Everyone will get over it.
That's okay. It's funny
story though. All right,
so what are you doing at the gym today?
Back in trash nods leg that today,
which I'm not looking for it to women.
Always be doing the legs. Okay, I'm done.
Why women be doing their legs?
Yes.
Oh, for fuck's sakes. Jesus,
you spilled the watts lead
glasses of water on the floor.
I tell you this all the fucking time.
You're always leaving glasses of water
on the floor and this is what happens.
How many times a week do you knock over
a glass of water because you put it on
the floor?
How many times
are you done? Are you done? Yes, I'm done.
Can you say sorry for
spilling the water in here?
I'm sorry for spilling your water,
but also there's no bugs.
There's no buts and a, sorry, you read
this. Sorry you're not, I'm sorry.
I spilled the one that's the podcast.
Everybody else. See you on Thursday.